i had a non-traditional path to wall
street i went to a school that wasn't a
typical feeder school
and at the last second i i gave
consideration to doing the two-year
analyst program on wall street quite
frankly had a little bit of success and
unexpected success and and fell in love
with
with wall street and decided to to stay
in the industry um and progress through
my career why i gravitated to stanford
was really around the innovation um
disruption some of the the technology
aspects and and how the world is going
to be different you know 10 20 30 years
from now and the belief that you need
this sort of background and
understanding all of these currents to
be a successful leader in the future
silicon valley in my opinion has woken
up to this industry and wanting to
disrupt it i think financial
institutions really need to figure out
and i think they're doing it in a lot of
ways it's how do i how do i take these
this underlying industry if you will on
the disruption side seriously how do i
how do i figure out how to work with
them how do i figure out how to partner
with them being out at stanford sitting
in palo alto meeting with all the
venture capital funds seeing what the
professors were talking about with the
students are learning it made me realize
that innovation and disruption
is is really here to stay you can't you
can't compete with it
[Music]